After all we've been through.
It can't be for nothing.
We finish what we started.
There's no half-way with this.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie.
This will be my last of us.
Episode 9 Finale Trailer.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs
and references to the game,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I will do videos for Last of Us
Season two.
They they confirmed
they're making it. Pedro Pascal
Said they might start
filming it by the end of this year.
I'll talk a little bit about that
at the end of this video
and it'll last of us Season
two video after the finale comes out.
Careful for spoilers through episode eight
if you haven't seen it.
Just because we have to talk
about everything that just happened.
But the title of the finale is
Look for the Light.
It's a reference to the Fireflies motto
that you saw drawn on all the buildings
in episode one,
and it's meant to complete Joel
and Ellie's
arc that you saw from the first episode
because the title of episode
one was the first part of their motto.
So episode one to episode Nine's
title is literally their full motto.
When you're lost in the Darkness,
look for the Light.
They also use it because the finale is
basically their last arc in the game,
where they find the fireflies at Salt Lake
City, Utah, as you see in the trailer,
including Marlene, who Joel and Ellie
haven't seen since episode one,
One Journey ends, another begins
at the end of episode eight,
when Ellie frees herself
from David's clutches
and she and Joel
find each other and take off.
She is meant to be broken inside.
Like the showrunner
Neil Druckmann said that she is basically
a broken person at this point, more
so than she already is.
Like she's already experienced
all this trauma up to this point.
This is meant to push her
over the edge briefly.
So you're meant to enter
episode nine wondering if Ellie is ever
going to be able to rebound from that,
because up to this point,
she's always paraded around with a smile
on her face, annoying Joel
with her positivity being so optimistic
about the mission to save the world,
you're meant to wonder
now if she can ever be like that again.
And if you haven't played the games, it's
not a
spoiler to say the answer is kind of,
but not in the same way.
Like she can't completely undo
all the trauma that she just experienced.
She's fundamentally changed by this ordeal
with David,
A little piece of her died
inside, metaphorically.
But as you see her in the trailer,
it seems that
there's been a small time jump.
She does seem like she's talking to Joel
in a positive way,
like we need to finish what we started,
even though there's this melancholy tone
over all the scenes in the trailer,
it does seem like enough time has gone by.
By the time they reach Salt Lake City,
that she's feeling a little bit
better emotionally.
But you don't walk away from something
like episode eight,
forgetting about someone like David
that's going to stay with you
for the rest of your life.
That encounter is almost enough to turn
someone vegetarian
for the rest of their life.
Just starting at the beginning
of the trailer footage,
the first scene is of them on the highway
reaching Salt Lake City.
You can see on the road signs behind them
can be a way for the episode to orient
you where they are, just to show them
standing next to street signs.
It's probably been at least a couple weeks
time jump between the end of Episode
eight and Episode nine,
maybe more than that,
because it looks like they were on foot
for a lot of this journey.
It's also not snowing here.
It seems much warmer
and they've been heading north.
So that kind of implies a larger time jump
because it was the
middle of winter in episode eight, Ellie's
voiceover talks about their mission,
hoping that it won't be for nothing
because at this point in the trailer,
when they're entering Salt Lake City,
they don't know
exactly where the fireflies are
or if they're still there.
They're just hoping to find them.
Her voiceover has a sad tinge to it,
so it's hard to tell if it's actual dialog
from the end of the episode
or the beginning of the episode.
If you have played the game,
please don't post spoilers
for how the episode ends, because I do
expect the ending of the episode
to be pretty much exactly
like the ending of the first video
game, and her line of dialog
sounds like it could come from.
Later in the episode,
she sits in an abandoned car
and looks at her, scarred from the fungus,
wondering whether or not they'll be able
to create a cure from her immunity.
I've already explained
why she's immune to the fungus.
It's basically because she has
a different type of fungus inside her.
This mutated that rejects the other fungus
when it tries
to infect her
like a good fungus inside her.
The outfit she's wearing is also
another one she wears in the games.
Pretty much all of her outfits.
Joel's everyone's outfits are based on
what they wear in the games
as they search for the fireflies.
They're seemingly attacked
with a smoke bomb,
thinking it's another group of raiders
freaking out.
They've grown weary, appropriately so,
because they just got done
dealing with the group of cannibals
when really what's happened
is that it's a couple of fireflies
trying to capture them
because they know who Ellie is.
They don't particularly care about Joel.
Ellie So valuable to them, though,
that they'll do anything to ensure
that they get their hands on her,
even though the whole idea here
is that Joel promised Marlene
to bring Ellie to them.
That's what he's trying to do.
Then the next scene in the trailer
is another huge video game, Easter Egg,
and it's actually a flashback
to On top of that,
this is Ashley Johnson playing
Ellie's mother, Anna, from the Games.
And in the Last of Us
games, Ashley Johnson
was also the original voice of Ellie.
So this whole flashback with Ellie's
mother, Anna, is another example.
The TV show adding scenes for the episodes
that weren't in the game
for extra context.
In the games,
you never really see Ellie's mother.
She never really gets any big scenes.
Ellie is only given a letter from her
mother wrote to her before she died.
She died about a day after
Ellie was born very quickly.
So Ellie never actually knew her parents?
She never knew her father either.
Most of the time in the games,
when she's thinking about her parents,
though,
she's just thinking about her mother.
And usually when she learns things about
her mother, it's from other characters.
You see Anna running from another infected
runner trying to consume her
and then backed into a corner in this room
looking like she's about to give
birth to L.A.
like she's about nine months
pregnant here about the pop.
How many marathons do you think you could
run while you're that pregnant?
She's been a real champ
here, escaping the infected for this long.
Within the world of the games,
Anna was a close friend of Marlene's
from before the fungus in 2003.
She worked as a nurse
at a hospital and became pregnant
with Ellie after the outbreak.
So remember, Ellie is only 14 years old
and present day in the outbreak happened
about 20 years ago, just before she died,
she wrote a letter to Ellie that
she would read when she was old enough,
and she made Marlene promise
to take care of Ellie and look after her,
which is why later, Marlene said
that she put her in the federal school
during the events of Episode one
without Ellie really knowing who Marlene
is or what her connection to her mother
was, Marlene doesn't
reveal every single thing
about her mother to Ellie
when she first started caring for her.
So throughout the games, Ellie continues
to learn more and more about her mother.
At some point
long after Ellie's mother had died,
Marlene became a leader of the fireflies
and continued to look after her.
And that's
when she put her in the federal school,
because, as she said,
that was the safest place for her to be,
even though it was a total crap
town in the games.
Marlene only gives Ellie
the letter from her mother, and that's it.
But the show is giving us the events
of Ellie's birth, so it's a huge deal.
Abby, Like House of the Dragon
or Game of Thrones,
doing a huge flashback
with Aegon the Conqueror
during the War of Conquest,
uniting Westeros, most of Westeros
because it didn't conquer Dorne,
so it was like the Six Kingdoms
and Dorne for a while.
And because we are talking about HBO show
Side Note, I will be doing videos
for House of the Dragon Season 2,
and they also plan
to eventually do Aegon's
Conquest as a series,
but probably not for a while.
Then in the trailer
they jump back to present day with Joel
walking through a construction
site, looking kind of frantic
and then another time jump later
in the episode to him shooting his way
through the Firefly's main hospital
that they're operating out of.
Keep in mind that this is the fireflies
that are in the hospital
that he's shooting at
and they're shooting back at him, both
trying to kill each other.
So remember,
all the way back to episode one,
he was originally promising to Marlene
to bring Ellie to the fireflies,
but without getting into big spoilers,
something really big winds up happening
and he winds up fighting the very people
that he promised to help.
And also remember,
even before the events of episode one,
he absolutely hated the fireflies.
But the idea is that Joel hates
pretty much all the groups on the show,
all the different powers
that be like he hates Pedra
just as much as he hates the fireflies,
and as much as he hates the hunters.
In fact,
Tommy's group is probably the first group
that he's warmed up to a little bit.
I feel like we can't really talk
too much about why Joel would be
fighting the fireflies in the finale
without getting into spoilers,
so we'll wait to the actual finale episode
video to talk about that when it airs.
But then the trailer jumps
back to the beginning of the episode
with Ellie and Joel
on the outskirts of Salt Lake City,
looking out over the city with her saying
there's no halfway with their mission.
They need to finish what they started.
But the phrase is meant to have a double
meaning in the context of the episode.
When Ellie's speaking it, she's talking
about their mission with the fireflies.
Like she expects
that they'll find the fireflies.
Marlene,
even though she doesn't totally understand
how they'll use her immunity
to create a cure,
she thinks they'll perform
a bunch of medical tests and figure it out
somehow and seems pretty optimistic
about the outcome.
Like, this is a big deal.
Literally and emotionally.
They might wind up saving the human race.
She's still a little bit
naive about things.
The double meaning in finishing
what they started, though, is
what did they also start?
They also started to become a family.
And Ellie, like father and daughter
in on Joel side of this, he's
going to do what he thinks he needs to do
to protect his new daughter.
Like this time he won't fail to protect
Ellie the way that he feels like
he failed to protect his real daughter.
Sarah then tests
no matter the consequences.
So just be prepared
for Joel to make some really,
really hard choices in the episode.
If you have play the games, please don't
post spoilers about the details of that.
They'll probably add
some scenes like the flashback to Ellie's
mother, Anna, and her birth.
More scenes with Marlene
the Fireflies for context.
But largely the episode should play out
pretty closely to the end of the events
of the first game.
Right now, Pedro Pascal's
that they might start filming season
two before the end of this year.
I don't think they get it out by 2024,
meaning to be 2025 for season two.
They're also probably going to start
filming The Mandalorian Season
four by the end of this year too.
So it'll be interesting to see how Pedro
Pascal juggles both of those shows.
I will do Another
Last of Us Season
2 video after the finale comes out
and just talk more about
what's going on with that
and how they're going to adapt
the plot of the Last of Us 2 Game,
because they already talked a little bit
about season two.
If you spotted any Easter eggs
or references in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video,
write them below in the comments
in my full Episode 9 video we'll post
next Sunday after they release it
in my Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 2 Video.
We'll also post later this week as well.
Everyone click here for my full Last of Us
Episode 8 Video and Easter
Eggs and click here for my Full
Mandalorian Season 3 Episode Videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
And this is the way.